mais juste avant vous va jouer avec ce
qu'on connaissait isabelle maury du beau
jeu oui je prends cette séquence by paul
on va jouer à blake de mamie joly c'est
récent mené 3-0 à l'ailé chérie je fais
ça la première qui rit a perdu vers le
voir elle avait des blagues ici pendant
que l'autre lit la blague vous devez
prendre une cuillère dessous on va
démarrer par vous
tania kelly dire une blague à isabelle
morini-bosc attention il s'appelle vous
vous attendez vous prenez la soirée
attention et vous devez partir
six ouvriers c'est un point pour l'autre
c'est parti c'est un vieux qui demande à
sa femme chérie pourquoi les girafes
ont-elles denoncourt et sa femme lui
répond parce qu'elle perd les pieds tu
peux recommencer
alors là une autre visite de vieilles
vaches discute ça ne fait pas peur c'est
histoire de vache folle
l'autre répond m'en fous je suis un
lapin bien à vous attention pour la star
vous avez presque pas tant sur enfin
mouche cinqueterre aller aux jo quelle
est la différence entre un vieux regarde
moi quand je te parle c'est bien la
différence entre un vieux matelas draps
nappes en dehors on leur fait qu'elle
demande quelle est la différence en
prend mieux requin est un vieux rouquin
juin les chefs du père et l'autre les
dents de la mer
[Rires]
pour l'instant ça marche
bravo tania pas njawe
j'adore cette séquence je suis foot
c'est un vieux et son petit-fils discute
papy pourquoi il n'ya plus de mammouth
parce qu'il n'ya plus de chats pout
[Musique]
[Rires]
tania les excès excellente saga vraiment
attention à vous tâtez bien après une
prévu la baisse est donc ça je peux
faire ça à 8h à vieux regarde ma demande
à son ami
pourquoi est ce que michael va à la
porte
on a mis ne sais pas alors oui rétorque
parce que je vois la meilleure à celle
là est proche et la dernière c'est la
dernière
pour l'instant c'est tania qui a été le
plus sérieuse mais isabelle vous êtes
très drôle également attention tania
stable ou la dernière a2a oui j'adore
les chiens je ne serai pas tout
bonsoir l'année prochaine ses employés
mettez le juste
[Applaudissements]
alors attention vous avez aimé la soupe
c'est acquis de manger à boma pas bon tu
es bien chez moi je sais ma nourriture
préférée
2 les olé écouter vos des philosophes
qui co se retrouve dans une pomme vous
avez déjà vu de vidéos ce qui convient
je ne savais même pas du prix du shit
year je ne savais pas que vous habitiez
le quartier écho se retrouve dans une
pomme
tiens je ne savais pas que vous habitiez
le quartier très bien ma dernière s'est
en rien de moi ces deux vieux canard
dans une marre et il y en a un qui fait
c'est perdu
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi la fois de la blague adore
ces histoires c'est con mais j'adore ça
c'est de vue qu'un hormones dans une
main et y en a qui dit à l'autre coin
coin elodie bah merde c'est ce que je
voulais dire
regarde ça j'adore aller voir une très
courte qui marche très bien
eyes et ses bras c'est ce qu'on m'a dit
[Rires]
si ça pouvait être vrai aller au ciel
est d'abord c'est parfois les maîtres
nageurs plus des doigts c'est pourquoi
les maîtres nageurs plus des doigts
ouais non j'aime bien merci à l'est le
shérif avant de retrouver jean luc
lemoine